thank everybody time thank you for
coming here today
hopefully this is gonna go well my I
don't have voice or probably no mid of
the seminar my was gonna end my computer
crash three times yesterday and I have
learning in my title so uh so we see how
this goes
everybody's doing learning my president
has gone through focus on the learning
aspects of control and a few months from
here people are using learning for
self-driving cars for manipulation for
walking and for became police problems
okay it's say I
he goes out Sunday the world of AI
artificial intelligence I'm actually one
of the faculty that believe that we have
oversold this term and faculty actually
haven't done too much for stopping this
nonsense and if you just look at the
investment on self-driving cars alone we
have eighty million this an old numbers
probably are around 120 the ol Apollo
mission costed I did the math roughly
150 billion dollars in today's money
okay so we're very close it's not
self-driving car out there but what I'm
going to do is just be way too easy I've
been in a lot of presentations to
criticize the IP so I'm not going to be
negative it's very easy to show things
that fail so actually I will try to be
positive and tell you a little bit my
view of learning and where can be
beneficial okay so have the out divided
talk is divided into four parts what I
think three key ingredients for autonomy
constrains predictions and learning my
classifications learning of this
overused word and then I'll tell you
this is the technical parts gonna be
this technique that I call iterative
learning predictive control and then
some sorts of what is new what is old
the real benefits of learning you can
stop me anytime you on our website there
is video and thought and slides and
papers you can see a 30-minute version
of this talk on the recent Congress are
learning for dynamics and control at MIT
with together with the many other really
interesting talks from people doing
and control i'm directly next year that
one is in December okay so come there
it's gonna be the second conference on
elf for DC okay
you see lot of nice videos Marco said
thanks to a funding city of Hyundai
Motor CEO and CTO of Alex ow and then
sugar from next record many other
companies the work of learning and PC
was started five years ago by guru Sonia
great thanks goes to him on putting this
together
I teach when we teach control so
undergrad student I reused the inverted
panel right now many of you have taken
over everything a question for the
pendulum everybody this is taught to
display explain to you what is nonlinear
dynamics abstraction how you do
linearization with is an equilibrium
point
what is stability Lyapunov stability and
how you do a stabilizing control design
what is the problem is that once you
learn this you really won't be able to
do not even the simplest control design
in any of these systems okay and why
because all the systems I have
constrains in the design okay so what
I've been trying to think is how we
think a lot about undergrad education or
do we change this problem so we can
actually teach constraints and so now
I'll take the inverted pendulum I
replace the stick with a wire and so
this becomes a ball in a cut prop I'm
going to swing I'm moving the cup I'm
going to swing the cup so that the ball
goes into the cup as simple as this if
you can ride modern with eight states x
and y position velocity for the cup x
and y for the ball there are constraints
on the acceleration of the cup right
because you can't go you know super fast
and catch it immediately there are
constraints in the relative state the
ball the distance you have on the cup
has to be less than L okay and your goal
is described as a constraint at the end
at some time T the ball has to be in a
cup very simple or what we teach doesn't
really apply here right just going to
bring the ball in the cup
don't care about no stability
linearization equilibria and so on okay
so constraints dominate dominate the
design for this problem and the simplest
way to do this to the most disciplined
ways to write it down
as a infinite horizon optimal control
problem where infinite here is a very
longer isin it's the T where the cup
will go the ball will go in the curve so
here you have some costs you have the
model of the ball in the cup you are
looking for a set of feedback policy you
have constraints that I've just
described before and at some time T the
ball has to be is your target set the
bullets to win the cup we all know you
take classes on this topic that this is
a hard problem even if your model is
perfect even if your constraints are
static okay and in MPC that's what I've
been doing for most of my career what we
do we actually take this longer isin or
infinite horizon problem and we solve it
as a mu short very short finite horizon
problem that's all what it is in NPCs
the exactly same prop cost constrains a
model the longer isin is replaced now
with n ok looking for a set of feedback
policy that minimizes costs and these
constraints NPC applies the first input
and keeps repeating the optimization the
next time step so it's nothing but the
first feedback policy PI 0 implemented
with actual current state so what it is
you take the first policy and implement
the first day it's a big community there
are conference there are any NPC
conference from both robotics and as
well as it started actually in the
chemical world ok in chemical
engineering world there's a lot of
theory there's computation is practice
the classical Theory actually tells you
this is the first example that in my MPC
class that if you do not design the cost
to go and the terminal set properly
nothing is going to work even for linear
perfect models why because you're short
side so in the ball in the cup you are
look you're very short side you have to
swing in it this the ball and you
basically want to make sure the lens in
a set where you can catch it ok so this
side a special property is called a
control environment set that's not
enough you need a cost on this set which
is a controller Poona function that
actually guides you towards the catch ok
and so these two objects are well
started there is hundreds of papers and
books on control even function very
unset
the the theory goes like this and
environs that is the basically extension
on equilibrium point if you it's a set
of point of states roots they exist and
input that the next step you are in this
set of states okay it's again an
exercise an equilibrium point how do you
compute this here is a simple example
linear discrete time model your goal is
to bring the state to 0 and you have
input constraints you're going to write
down my set controllable in one step to
ask the previous set of points for which
the exist any input such that ax plus B
U is equal to 0 so the next state you go
in 0 and you satisfy input constraints
so this object the set of X such the
existent you remember you probably start
with some very linear algebra when you
have an existing that is a projection
right so these two computers of you need
to project and projections are hard and
now you have the one-step controllable
set and environment is a fixed point
iteration of this procedure ok so yes
you can use MPT toolbox for linear
systems I contributed to some of these
algorithms when I was a PhD student or
for instance you can solve for nonlinear
systems trying to find the level set of
a midterm joke of a bellman English ok
and this is a student of Claire Tomalin
was a professor here I'm gonna talk I'm
going to refer to environ set a safe sex
a French call a the viable sets ok
control environment safe set of
variables that are all the same thing
control upon a function it's a function
such that it's positive definitely that
decreases along the closed loop less
than the stage cost ok are you design is
functions a game is very hard in general
if you take the simplistic linear model
that you take a quadratic function what
you can do you could and you have
constraints you can solve they'll cure
for the unconstrained problem then you
can compute an environment the
closed-loop system and this is their QR
okay
and now subject to state constraints and
input constraints this you do it the way
I showed you before now you can say that
quad lqr optimal cost is a controllable
function in the terminal set and you can
do this was quadratic and functionally
my sum of
approach come so there's a lot of
literature very hard if you ever played
with these tools finally control over a
function for in ten states with
constraints is basically impossible this
part okay so what is the computation
tell you well I need in MPC I need to
compute this policy there are two ways
the first one I call offline based you
do a lot of calculations offline and
then in real time you just applied the
Polish so you compute the policy about a
the policy at the state that's just a
lookup table one way to compute this
policy is dynamic programming for
instance right value iteration and we
all know that you need some form of
grading more than five states things
don't work well sit in some model
aggregation reduction okay by the way
everything in approx then I'm programmer
in first maligning is about completing
this policy this is what a is right this
is function approximation okay
the other way is actually online simple
what I mean online based offline you
just set up an optimization problem and
then online you do a complex algorithm
okay so France we could use an interior
point method or sequential quadratic
program this doesn't give your policy
gives you the policy at the given state
okay that's the online approach very
hard to run this in real time and
embedded solvers however if you convex
if I then there are fast convex solver
and this is really what I've been
focusing over the past ten years how to
balance this online versus offline
approach there are excellent online
based solvers you can make your startup
based on IP opts and it is it's just
accident convex and on convex or CV axe
there are offline you know that there is
you know the what is called the explicit
solution for linear systems that's what
was my PhD work but you can pre-compute
some of this table without grading
however this works on if your
constraints again constraints is low not
state that works resolution works in
hundred dimension if you have three
constraints
people working on mixing pre-computation
and online optimizations are MPC on fpga
we did some work with sergey Ricky
three years ago we're actually we were
removing getting moving away from
digital computer running MPC in
microseconds we have a nanosecond
implementation with just using an analog
computer favor you should um if you
don't have any of these tools MPT y'all
me picado see the ax comes up you have
the ivory tool but there is an issue to
go like this and should go back and pick
one of this learn one okay good and you
know just not advertise my words you
know that the [ __ ] on nine is controlled
by Sylvia the landing is controlled by
cbx account so we recently we had large
brockmore presenting was very
interesting talking and how it designs
the fins and is using real time
optimization tool and rocket okay what
do we are do you do what you do in
practice
these are self-driving car like is same
as any the cars you see are there is a
test and somewhere all the many
companies in the bear doing these things
they have MPC at some point either in
the barrier planning meaning do I will
take or not to either into motion
planning or in the past fall okay they
do because you need to replant okay
things will move around you're uncertain
you need to optimize and reply and so
what happens if you use a formal
approach the one I should before it
happens that there's no environment
terminal costs you play with your Eisen
okay and actually there are companies
that give you data over human drive
withdrawn the human drives drive and you
can use this data to actually compute
your cost okay the cost goes you
basically data driven cost to go it's a
lot of what a lot of companies are using
out there don't minimize the way policy
this is very hard most of the time you
minimize of an open-loop sequence okay
you'd you know
theory to write a theorem you need time
inviting constraints most of the time
theorem is with time learning stuff is
where it's hard okay then you need to
burn the way this changes with time but
everything out there is time varying you
have your constraints depend your area
where you can write depends of the
agents okay where they're going to go
their forecaster and certain and will
change with time
so most of the time what you do
you you basically replace the terminus
consider with sample based scenarios
okay these are all the five tough things
that I believe is going to happen for
the my pedestrian you cannot use a
genetic solvent exploit the structure
this optimization problem you need to
smarten Ischl eyes it and you know in my
talk I'm going to write you initialize
the state with the major state we know
that localizing yourself is probably one
of the hardest problem right and this is
where you want there's a lot of work
going on and you know these are not to
this one of our tests not too different
what you see out there this is run in
real time optimism is running at the
optin real time and again if you see a
pedestrian this pedestrian was
forecasted its motion the motion will
change the constraint which will change
the solution so let me go to Outback on
me the constraints the predictions are
important okay there's no way you can do
any autonomous system challenge Odom's
without forecast let's move to learn
okay as I say this is over it's an
overused word so I'll try to give you my
definition learning and the idea is that
again if when we teach this inverted
pendulum we done use the fact that in
many of these examples there is this
some of these talks are iterative
there's a peace at least any a piece of
it that is repeated okay this is my ball
in a cup
this is Luca you give him a snot it
doesn't know that beginning okay
and these economic Japanese toy and it
keeps trying and yes try the week before
doing this video but at the end I
succeed is very happy okay so here's my
I've been thinking about a lot about
learning looking at literature so here's
my Constitution look it's three aspects
okay first one is you try you didn't
want to do a task and you learn to do
these tasks but just keep trying like
kicking a ball mid-air okay this is I
call this skill acquisition okay
the second when you keep kicking balls
me there then you get really good at it
okay then you become actually this is
what I call the guide is built he knows
how to kick balls me there and then he
keeps doing it and doing and a
performance improvement is what brings
him at the top level and then if you
keep kicking
for all your laughing you just go in
open loop okay and we while you're doing
this your computational load goes down
so you can do other things right the if
you think about it's very interesting
I've been looking this video with
faculty it doesn't cause loop even on
the touch is looking it's trying to
close the loop on this vision system
okay this is it doesn't is not touching
it okay good so if you go to the nearest
science department they say oh this is
too simple I agree
okay it is not a standard definition of
learning the acquiring a skill improving
performance and Lord and this happens
you know it's quite complex with this
happens you know we acquire skill it get
battered it and then as we get better
some is stored somewhere in our body and
we do other things it's a it is a major
simplification but I claimed it is
enough for robotics okay as a matter of
fact in the robotics field you have the
learning from expert instruction stand
for this one of you know a key player in
this transfer learning where you do not
know how to do something okay and then
you try keep trying again you succeed
performance improvement this is probably
by far the most at most of the
reinforcement learning paper they will
write sentence like this suboptimal
successful trajectory from a
demonstrator available this means you
know how to do it in the first place it
means that you are giving you an
environment a control community right as
human control mindset is available know
without telling y'all to compute it okay
and then all the load reduction is all
these people doing look up generation
neuron nectar and chips trying to once
you ever Polly's how to make it fast
computing so I'm going to how does it
look these three forms looks for about
when is my one to ten scale vehicle I
teach a custom vehicle dynamics we use
this for our undergrad students this is
skill acquisition you try to park and
it's a very complicated where either at
the dynamics there are constraints
there's the friction which is not well
modeled between the tire and are 10 or
11 iteration you keep trying and you get
you do drift parking
okay skill acquisition performance
improvement you go you ask this card
learn how to race faster and faster
though saw this problem minimum time so
you go
you'd go center lane very slow I can and
as you acquire data you improve your
model you improve your cost and you get
better better okay and at some point
this would go as fast as you can
I should try to increase the video here
is there a way to increase that with you
it's okay it's fine to hear them where
they will scratching okay
computational road reduction once you
have learned the minimum time solution
but you see this is the lap time as the
lap goes down okay now you can start
predicting you can use your data run
your your state to actually look up the
solution you see the computational load
goes down 10x is not predicting anymore
and the cost is the same just you're
doing same life time with 10x of your
conditional load on the CPU okay so this
is the third part of my talk how we do
this just show you some of more of the
math behind it's very simple it's a
super simple idea you can cut it up in
today when we go to tonight on this
weekend yeah I don't Sunday okay
iterative learning pretty of control
here's the idea assume this task is an
iterative you start from always from the
same state and always this final state
and my notation will tell you that we
are lose this double index this is time
this is the iteration number okay
this is the state of the system at time
T at iteration zero I will explain these
things for the turret if the performance
improvement case so I'm assuming
somebody has given you the zero feasible
one okay so and then I'll tell you more
about how if how you compute the first
one this is the state editor shown one
at time T okay so because you have
changed your policy then the trajector
will look different okay in practice
okay what happens that if you fix a
control point is my MPC policy of editor
ations you are fixed then I keep trying
I really will have a cloud of points
right because there is nice and that's
why you have and there is a lot of
uncertainty and so this enduring the
reinforcement learning communities are
called roll out so the iteration you fix
a policy and any of a hundred rollouts
per iteration okay so this is a plot
where you see two iterations two
policies and 100 rollouts per iteration
what I'm going to show you is all
deterministic you can go on and come on
our website you can see the stochastic
version the robust version the students
have to write paper and you can the
basic ideas always it's very simple it's
always the same for the the same and of
the deterministic a so are you not going
to see cloud of points you're going to
spending the idea in the deterministic
perfect model case ok remember the
biggest issue with a PC how do we get
this terminal causal thermal constraint
well can I use data to update my cost
function cost to go and my safe set and
possibly my model lets us see my
mother's perfect I'll give you a few
hints on what happens when the model is
different
here's the idea let's focus on safe set
assume somebody gave you a trajectory
that brought you from access to access
state input pairs okay what can you say
about this stadium put this set of
points it's a controlling mindset if you
got on the perfect model if I'm here
there is an input sequence that will
bring me to the terminal set it's a set
it's a discrete controlling mindset
right okay so what do you do well use
this is a terminal condition of your NPC
at the next iteration so iteration one
you start again from here you are short
side you look ahead but you have to land
in either here or here or here or here
or here okay and so I'm looking two
steps ahead I'll and I decide to line in
here that's not the best trajectory this
point here okay is where I'm going to
land as I apply the input that I
predicted if there's no model mismatch a
repeat optimist
again and again look at this this is
what you know the effing seafaring from
an NPC the tractor we look different
because you do your eyes are now shift
this is the best thing to do now to line
in act zero four and so on right so in
at the end because you're landing into
an environment said this is what MPC
proves that you will succeed you'll end
up in excess even if you're
short-sighted because in the worst case
if you can find a solution you repeat
exactly the one you've done before okay
but you're in same page but there is
something that if your optimization
savage something didn't sound right when
i when i was describing this yeah
optimal we have to prove that very good
and then we also have something from a
computational point of view when i said
or or are not good every time
optimization guy say or something as to
ORS are bad okay mixing these
optimizations np-hard problems right
okay but so at the end assume that you
have these data points the union of the
samples safe set before and now my
trajectory is another safe set and in
general the safe side that iteration j
is all the data points where you
converged editor asia when you've got to
the goal okay here's how you get rid of
the or for linear constraint system so
if you take the convex hull of these
points then this is that you can prove
very simple this is linear algebra that
this is a controlling by and set so you
get you don't have to solve a mixed
integer problem you can actually land in
the convex hull of the stored data in
this way you also get rid of a lot of
data okay so what about the cost I told
you about X at the terminal said about
the cost to go simple idea as well you
have meteor issue you start from X 0 you
somebody showed you are to go this now
this time the state is in one dimension
because I want to plot those so the cost
to go somebody gave you a demonstration
to go out to go to access by four points
I have the actual measured data and
compute the actual cost
at these points hx0 to the realized
state with the realized input the
realized state with their as input plus
were there was this and so on okay take
the epigraph of this point so take the
epoch of the convex hull of this point
it's called a biocentric approximation
my claim you can prove it that this is a
control upon a function how do you write
this is very simple this you're looking
for a set of multipliers that minimize
the costs is written as sum of store
data such that the convex combination of
the data points give you the current
state X simple convex problem okay and
it is a control upon a function y
because if I jump from here to here
that's the stage the decrease is exactly
H remember that was the property of
control upon a function and if you jump
from here to here the degree the
decrease of the cost will be for sure
less or equal than any convex function
jumping from the same point to here okay
so what you did the next step same thing
you repeat literation okay used to
compute the actual measure cost and you
take the biocentric approximation of the
old data points very important point
here this is not higher on the slider
their iteration this function the QX
these are the stored points is a
controller Poona function okay I have
questions good so this is my LM PC do
MPC however but with these two simple
changes change the safe set use the safe
set edit iteration the way I explained
it before and this cost to go as the
barycentric approximation so which means
minimize over the lambda of the q okay
if you read one of our papers no
transactions going to be three main
theorems which is what your colleague
was asking one was if you keep doing
this few we're safe before and there's
no model mismatch you be safe at the
next time step constrain guarantees at
beta version j in pi constraints
guarantees iteration
j+ well it also you can guarantee that
the costs at the previous iteration is
going to be less or equal than the
greater evil than the costs at the next
iteration so you have performance
improvement or equality okay and also
for linear constraint system converts to
the global optimal solution not going to
do you the proof are going to explain
the proof but the proofs are actually
simple they're all based on this
property of control upon a function that
the trick is actually to compute the
function once you have the once you have
the function of that property that's
what the literature has shown in the
past that you have guarantees of safety
and performance improve okay okay well
how did with this was we came up with
this idea of those five years ago then
we spend I personally spend a couple of
years trying to figure out why nobody's
implemented this in this way is it
really new way and so on so what's
happening and so what's happening in
reinforcement learning so first of all
there's a lot of literature connecting
optimal control enforcement learning
basic as Dimity basic is a new book that
this semi very nice connected
enforcement early and optimal control
just came out a few weeks ago there's a
survey on control system magazine there
is my colleague Ben Rex which is a nice
blog and is talking about reinforcement
learning and optimal control but there
are differences ok this is a continuous
state formulation I'm not discretizing
the state constraint satisfaction is
obtained in here and usually considers
fractions not really a focus on RL at
least not in a formal way tis done the Q
function I learned locally based on cost
model exploration I'll tell you more
about this okay so if you just want to
remember one picture you ever you have
done your DP example somebody must be is
plenty of alliteration and you're at
some point this one looks like you have
a grid like this you know the changes
with time and the green the more you
iterate the more green you get the green
means close to the optimal okay this if
you do il MPC is different you're going
to get set of points
try and their orange because they're not
optimal at some point you keep trying to
get more points and then you've got the
optimal solution to go from here to here
and then you take the convex hull and
the bias and the approximation you have
a local controller here this is the P
validation this is ILM PC it's a forward
well it's a forward validation DP it's
backward okay what'd you do what'd you
lose by doing this you lose that you
have only local properties okay here
instead this you get a global solution
what you gain you're not grading okay
and you can switch you know you're not
going therefore you can solve problems
and high dimension okay if you'll carry
this
what is you'll see next what's
interesting is that in DP you one step
backwards iteration makes total sense
because it's global okay and so it makes
no sense to do two-step you could do to
step work to step backward iteration but
if there is no need of doing it in Ariel
NPC because actually so you in the night
program you're exploring because your
global and you're going to every point
in L NPC you explore because you're
predicting so if you do a four way
duration with one step is not going to
work
you need longer prediction to explore
okay so that's also actually we have a
nice to you and tells you how long it
should predict so that you can start
exploding exploring the you know your
controllability matrix has to lose rank
if you are Savior bug and if you know a
lot about approximately nine programming
but in this birth checkers book there is
concept of aggregations okay people if
you have high dimensional state then you
don't want to done any program in high
dimensional state you do some
aggregation you have to figure out how
to get this aggregation probably that's
very hard but then if you have
aggression probability you do this DP in
a lower dimension of space and then you
go up by this aggregate in the original
space okay
so il NPC is basically telling you let
NPC explore and will basically generate
aggregate state this is a double
integrator with noise
these are dilated states over a hundred
rollers if you take the convex all about
the
these are my if you own your state of
the Markov decision process state one
state two everything inside the red
state three state four test so these are
the aggregate state and instead of using
a linear it costs to go a linear
expression your feature i'm using i'm
telling you use barycentric
approximation as simple as this okay
good you know and your Besant
approximation looks really cool i they
look better than the value function
approximation but that's just a taste
let's go back to race this is my race
problem if you want to learn these
things you know you have a Chris gerdes
here is the world expert on racing out
of so few these classes are just
beautiful that lectures as well here's
written a minimum time probably to go
from 0 till the end you have some
dynamics you have some constraints so
how would you solve this if you if you
take em and make it class how would you
solve this problem you write down the
equation of motions i spent a whole
semester off of the semester on this
these are just you know a body frame to
go up a frame but these are the earlier
equations and the hardest part in here
are actually the forces to the weaker
right the forces to the vehicle are no
linear function of size leap angles we
preach the friction confusion and normal
load and this you know their entire
conferences on tires you can go to
conference on tires they talk about this
viscoelastic material they tell you how
to do this with final methods are to put
you know i should you blend rubber with
steel and for control point of view just
do this the nonlinear approximate
okay that's that's my tire and then lane
approximation looks like it's higher if
it's asked for this very low fit size
because you have less friction okay
it is a tough object and by the way if
you're thinking where is the steer where
is the input here well the steering by
stealing your changes sleep the sleep
angry at this direction between the
wheel direct this is the angle between
the wheel direction and the vehicle
direction so that's your one input with
steering by rattling you change the
sleep ratio that's the the wheel speed
versus the vehicle speed so and then
there's this other concept of race
if you'd open a book on racing they will
teach you about the race line if these
complex things to compute because he's
in general solving dynamic programming
either you have you as you're
approaching a curve you have to open you
have to slow down cut in and then open a
game right this is called the optics
usually so the classic approach would
tell you to run some experiments get
data train amusing train sorry identify
the coefficients of the function okay
and this neither of your time model you
compute the race line okay with the nine
programming and then we design a path
folder to follow the race line that's a
very good design for doing racing and
actually part following could be PID but
because the mother's heart you can do
interesting things on path following to
follow the race line this is my
controller okay is an air il NPC this is
the indicator function tells you it
skips salmon until you end you finished
you got to the target okay this is the
many other code minimum time this is the
Q function as I showed you before as you
keep iterating this is the safe set as I
showed it before there is an S C because
I'm using a convex safe set so the
convex hull to make computation
tractable and don't think I didn't show
you why do you get ABCD from don't know
linear dynamics well as very simple idea
you take the kinematic equation you know
them well so you do linearize symbolic
linearization and then you take the
dynamic the dynamic equations which
where this F appears which you don't
know well and use simple simple linear
aggressor so it is a kernel function
okay which tells you use data locally
only around you in space and time and
this is a linear multiplier of your
features which are States and inputs as
simple as this now you lost all the
guarantees the theorem doesn't work
anymore because all the terms are
totally performance improvement and so
on it's gone okay
of course you can do it robust and there
are papers that you can find from my lab
about what what which kind is can you
give when she wants you
state these coefficients but in general
tart by works extremely well this is my
our 110 the code is online this is at
the end once you have learned after 25
steps it goes from 35 seconds to 5
seconds ok you can see the race line
again
I'm not telling the race line I'll tell
me what the Terek Ephesians I'm telling
anything then we had knitting knitting
was a Stanford grad came as a postdoc
together a joint project with Chris
characters that we said I want the
exactly the same code exactly the same
even the random seed okay to work on the
beaker because otherwise then if you
have to tune the big there's the
learning is fake right so if you the
exact same code has to be pushed on our
big car and these are the experiments
what is just really works with different
tracks the big car experiment looks like
this it's a pity you don't hear the
audio is there a way to increase over
here it's pretty Costa
okay this is our test track that was a
loop I wasn't happy about the cones we
we go down towards California improving
down and this is our nice nice test
track here I'm gonna show you just
experiments in this there is a u curve
and then there's a chicken here and same
code the game the different track left:0
the this this is one of this example
where the initial feasible solution it's
easy just drive very slow centerline
it's very boring you know this takes ten
minutes to go the whole lap but in to
gather data and then after so you can
see and that's only one piece hundred
seconds a lap 16 you go down to 40
seconds okay so they said lap 14 so
you're opening you see the chicken here
you go to the left you slow down and you
cut through the apex constraint
satisfaction right there good we can
spend hours looking at you know how cool
these plots are slowing down opening and
closing it's fear in a vehicle dynamics
class that's what we be doing every time
I and I'm close to my the end of the top
but every time student comes and say
this is it's very cool ask you do you
need all this to solve the problem do we
need all this machinery to solve this
problem
so do we need safe sets so yes you do
right if you don't put the safe set at
the end okay you're gonna violate your
constraints because you have no linear
dynamics we haven't tested this this is
it's no need to test it and simulation
shows you that you're gonna go just go
out okay
although anything wanted to try that do
you need to predict Euler and this is
the exactly I told you before you do if
you prayed if you have an MPC with a
shot with or item1
you don't Explorer you end up always
going center lane okay you can do
predict once you've learned is exactly
the idea of storage you don't
once you have a lot of data take apply
the input which is a convex combination
of your it's a weighted sum of your
stored input this is the stored in for
the time I of iteration J where these
optimal coefficients are given by
minimizing the barycentric function as
simple as this this is super quick 10x
of a factor and you're doing exactly the
same thing of course if you have
disturbed when something changes you
need to go back and predict the game
yeah five minutes five ten minutes to
come to end okay I this was my okay what
is new what is old a lot for sure
vocabulary as totally new I was writing
papers written simulation experiments
system I did this was my my vocabulary
when I was writing paper as a graduate
student my students have to write papers
where it's written episodes training
learning skill acquisition okay it is
the idea of using data to compute the
opponent functions if that is new okay I
think you know if you just think about
are we build this the opponent function
based on rollouts this is very different
than solving the level set of a minute
ago if I'm an equation of finding the
fixed point of asset value duration that
is different okay most importantly I'm
always have I always try to ask this
question what does it do for the good of
society and what is it can we use this
and we can use some of this in what is
new in this new architecture of remote
embedded system okay when I was a
student this was not existing you could
not upload a control on a car today you
know over there updates will be standard
the next three years Tesla is already
over there after it's right your
autopilot is updated and so these
millions of car that you that you'll
have access to so that you can update
the policies is actually quite
impressive and interesting and different
and when I was a student and whether
that is whether it's a good idea to do
that and test it as people are driving
that's a different story
okay but I'm saying that is new yeah
this is
my work with in the energy field this is
a solar power plants there you jur
twenty-seventh curriculum and they're
hundreds of football fields
okay have you ever seen one of these
official video there in this world just
this stage this is a 754 megawatt a guy
that's huge all solar powered this you
see these little rectangles they're
called solar trackers they track the Sun
and they are independently actuated
occur so they have a little bother here
takes but from the Sun there's a little
motor and they are independent to that
you will attract the Sun because then
you get 30% more energy than a fixed
tracker
okay and so if you think if a hundred
megawatt planners 2005 one red rose
excuse me 25,000 Rose you do the math
you basically end up with a million PIB
per gigawatt that you can update because
there are 10 P ideologist on this system
it's a super single system tracks the
Sun okay however it's hard to make it
robust because just there are so many
things I cannot be happy to share with
you if there's something that can go
wrong even just doing this okay there's
also another interesting thing that you
do not want to track the Sun when there
are clouds okay because there is more
diffuse light and direct lights so you
want to go to an angle which is optimal
depending on the cart condition okay so
of course you pull this data up of all
these trackers with the angle they are
so there are now there is tolling also
storage and all these data process here
a few miles from here by our software
okay so what are the real benefits of
learning is always something to ask and
when you when you hear about AI and
learning out there in the world mostly
this is my definition right skill
acquisition performance little reduction
but mostly the word out there is about
replacing the state without put step
number one so don't do a state observer
the classical way actually just put in
your network to so you can go output
feedback from camera that's quite
interesting okay the second step is to
say well replace the more than the
agents of your environment again don't
do any model base for
cuz just put a knight in your network
feedback phase and vision okay
that's step number two you got rid of
all the models and you put another in
your network here step number three
replace everything the setup server the
model with a big new net this is what is
called end-to-end control okay and I
claim that this a very bad idea okay and
it's not that claim I just we shouldn't
be teaching shouldn't be entertaining
this idea it is just not a good thing to
do and I'll be happy to you know
sometimes I give this talk at different
so there may be I'm preaching to the
choir here but sometimes people look at
me weird why you saying this we can you
know work with companies that work out
there it is hard to accomplish ition to
calibrate to test to explain to a lawyer
and we shouldn't be doing this however
and by the way I'm taking this class I'm
assuming this cause of my friend been
wrecked on machine learning and I'm
learning I'm a nerd things I know about
learning interesting new things but some
stuff I forgot I forgot about the
perceptron how many you got any computer
science here
remember the perceptron story this was
in your time telling you that the Navy
revealed the embryo when electronic
computer they expected to be able to
walk talk see write reproduce itself and
the conscious of its existence this is
New York Times 1958 okay and this is a
stochastic graded design with the hinge
loss that was the percept here
it's a stochastic gradient descent it's
the simplest form of great descent so I
would I'm saying maybe this dog feels
started with a big hype okay and so now
it just cannot stop it but anyway I
promised I would be positive right so
machine learning is good at this right
classifying and very good for my
searches so if you go back to the solar
tracker
you know what angles should you should
be in it depends on the cards and you do
it's very hard actually to make a cloud
imagine doing cloud modeling in the sky
right how they propagate
this is how any in real time is super
complicated so what you can use actually
put on your network on an image that it
looks at the sky and train a diffuse
light versus they like light estimators
to close the loop on these trackers okay
this is a product it's called to capture
yet to is machine learning
okay so this is a product this exists
these are all our solar patterns around
the world 20 gigabytes it's 40% of the
market you know this system deliver 6%
efficiency gain that are not 20 gig
about this is 1.6 Giga watt and this is
3 called power plants ok so these are
real benefits ok this has been obtained
by using data driven exploration ok
and so it is real this is the this is
down here a few miles from Stanford
annex record this next thing I want to
change when you buy a car Marco thinks
you're not going to be caught by cars
anymore Sam much will know much about
molded-in marker so in my lifetime I
think I still buy a car and if there is
desirey number 25 miles per gallon what
the heck you mean so it's this obsolete
and even if you know you Bears buying
cars they have to look at the efficiency
of their fleet right and so what do you
know what this numbers computer is a
test which is the same for all United
States and there's a profile which is
total nonsense right you can yeah this
our fleet of 5 hybrid vehicles a very
complicated powertrain running around
the Bay Area it's a big project with
Honda and we're basically recording data
as we go back and forth from Fremont to
Berkley and other areas and you know you
can basically learn traffic patterns and
deliver a powertrain control design for
that route ok
and so this can be done there's
technology for doing this and you know
this is what is in production in
production Larry Summers called charge
deeply in charge sustained use the
battery first and then use the internal
combustion engine for that road for that
traffic in the morning is not the best
thing to do you should use a blend of
battery and internal combustion engine
ok I'm done I think of another where I
told you about the role of constraints
in prediction told about interesting
problems what learning can bring and
actually I've been working a lot I'm
trying to think about out introduce all
this in our curriculum early you know
this is this is our experiment undergrad
experiments for teaching this robot to
do the the ball in the cup Charlotte is
not happier
so you know we all agree this is
learning not in the get out sense rather
you're calling this address okay so
there's no learning here but students
get excited when they see this thing
working okay this is Tony I guess he
didn't believe in the theory again
there's a lot of more videos on the web
thank you questions very good question
is actually from the system from the
setup we have it's very natural it's
longer is fewer outside if that problem
becomes infeasible okay the little LP
problem which means you are outside the
convex hull of any data point you have
then you're infeasible you need to
predict the game you don't have data
that tell that you can interpolate okay
so soon the way we do is act as soon as
that LP becomes infeasible then you
switch to an on line up with a line of
musician with prediction and by the way
that one doesn't need to be solving an
LP that could be and you're not though
that Interpol is the data okay but we
like health piece remember what the
policy is here okay so this is your
policy is the lambda come from some of
these optimization problem this
optimization problem strains a for a
given state it might be infeasible if
this is infeasible it means that you
don't have enough state that you can
interpolate to find the lambdas that
solve this constraint okay and so that's
the time to make predictions again yeah
yes yes
and so exhale like someone stole the
glass of water on the track and that
changes the tiles come into play with
the lamb correct so what will happen is
that this will becoming feasible you
would go back into predictions and now
your Colonel we lose the data the latest
data the company says it's local data in
space end times is a forgetting factor
with all data and that will learn your
patch at that point no guarantees right
you can make it I see and of course
there is no feasible controller that
just a temporary problem I come to
Stanford for predict all the time
there's disturbance and then I remember
see old truck when he can just begin
again autos if the condition big are
normal again does he have to relearn the
Sun dr. electro yoga but he can remember
the so again let's see let's use the
word learn instance let's go we store
and what we in this system here okay if
you go back to this guy here okay this
are the safe side and costs to go a task
and track dependent you change your
constraints or change your objective
these two things will change so you have
to recompute these two things even if
you now if you talk about so these are a
lot of things if you have a disturbance
that the task is always the same this
enters in here okay
and so yes this would be the if the
Colonel's are forgetting factor you
won't be able to predict that this is
gonna be it was there five minutes ago
so what is the best thing to do there is
you have to first format is the best
thing to do in that case yeah yeah is
there any way to it seems pretty data
efficient like only 10 or so iterations
and a lot before you can start getting
good performance but is there any way to
like generalize it in some way like if
you're trying to fly through a forest
gnarled forests are the same but they're
sort of similar
so wondering if there's a way to do some
sort of generalization without having to
relearn this question I guess that's the
holy grail of these people I don't have
a I don't have a good sense of it we are
thinking about it here it's always a
problem of if you are interested in
writing theorems or even is something
that works very well in practice and
sometimes the two are hard to combine
however what what I can say I mean your
point is very important this is the
critical part of this imagine imagine
trying where is this guy here is the lab
here but imagine try to basically know
you're doing MPC right and you have this
prediction see cost imagine trying to
update with value iteration the policy
around here that is not there won't be
data efficiency in real time at 20
milliseconds right so I think this you
know if you take what has been done in
the past you bring in this context and
maybe use some statistical learning
theory you can probably generalize these
things so some of my students that work
in this area yeah very good question
yeah these examples you know the
dynamics pretty well but say you wanted
to land a quadcopter optimally or
something you need to reason about
ground effect so you have a really bad
model and like don't even have a good
way of parameterizing it sometimes how
do you think you might apply this yeah I
don't know this is more like the
godmother I what if I knew it is you
know actually have a different questions
there I don't even know what the means
it works does it work means to join the
video for I cram it is it is a big
problem right this doesn't mean that
after a 100 duration so of course you
can do some statistics okay try hundreds
ok I want to have a model there learns
okay and over the past thousand
iterations okay my percentage of failure
decreases so I look at the window so
this could be a good definition it works
okay so in that case now you would need
you know in that case you need to you
need to pick a model okay and what I'm
claiming here I actually dastar's it you
say know very well the model but
not really I've used a linear kernel
here right you could use a piecewise
linear in the color of ordinary or not
talk the real ooh and if what I don't
have proofs and even have proofs veneer
network either so I think it's fine I
don't know if a linear kernel for your
application is just a simple inner
kernel would work or you need a deep
inner naca with the riilu activation
function clearly this neuron acts are
very good at classifying right so either
I haven't seen a very community story
that's a very good approximated
dynamical models with the exception of
okay of course they are piecewise linear
function piecewise Linear's better than
linear and in general